Ezard ran to the segment wire take a
less structured a humorous approach to
look at any topic that crosses my mind
relating to the subject of anime and
manga it contains my raw buys the pinyin
and it's for the purpose of creating
debate and or discussion so shouldn't be
taken too seriously got that great now
shut up and listen if you're a regular
watcher of my anime reviews then you
recently may have noticed me making some
not so pleasant comments about the state
of anomie in recent years and if you do
please slap yourself for making the show
the basis of about 90% of anime coming
out now you mindless moe a zombie so
instead of monetary bashing on his topic
in a yard random video I thought I could
address it directly so let's cut the
[ __ ] into action here and get
straight to the point of the video for
me the quality of anime coming out in
the past few years most notably from
2007 onwards have been very lacking at
least for the types and genres that I
generally look out for now before I get
into the Nitty Gritty of things I
thought I just points out what kinds of
anime for me I've been really missing
not me as a young the ground snarky
sarcastic a demure viewer but me as the
avid anime watch I started off as for me
the animes I haven't seen in a while are
those ones that can be considered epic
and yes I know this is one of the most
overused words in the Internet so let me
just explain what I mean I love those
types of animes that either in the sense
of scale or execution gives you a sense
of epicness it provides those moments
that sends chills down your spine and
goosebumps popping out of your every
pore with a gripping storyline it
results you in marathoning the entire
show in one night if you still don't
understand then you can take a look at
my list of epically cool anime
characters all my amv to get an idea of
what I mean since in terms of TV series
I have not seen one of these types of
animes in a while
in the wake of the recent male
slice-of-life boom I seem to be seeing
more anime centered around a group of
close knit friends who just 70% of the
time happen to be a bunch of cute girls
of wearing personalities doing different
variations of [ __ ] oh now put down a
pitchfork Moya fans this isn't gonna be
a 10 minute rant in how much I hate the
moai John rrah and yes I know that at
least in 2011 the whole more slice of
life Jonah is slowly dying out but the
fact remains that in recent years every
studio and that dog have been jumping on
his my bandwagon and trying to emulate
walk here to animation I've done which
to turn a group of cute did see girls
into a full-blown cash cow and that's
the thing to me it seems like anime
studios are less willing to take the
risk with some originality and would
rather sit on the fence and use the
tried and tested methods that were
ensure some viewers I'm sure of what
character design to go for no worries
just make sure that all characters
follow the color palette that
corresponds to a different skittle
flavor and make sure to give all girls
eyes their cover in these two thirds of
their face or I don't know how to make
like a [ __ ] cat or something that
always seems to bloody work not sure
what plot to give your anime
who needs a plot wagon simply put all
your characters in different situations
reminiscent of those little moments of
life that everyone can relate to an
apparently finds [ __ ] hilarious or
alternatively they can go down the route
that no one is willing to admit they
watch yet is always a guaranteed seller
that tits and ass route yes though we
had to admit at this [ __ ] sells if you
didn't we wouldn't be seeing a ketose on
going through its fifth season and mad
husband go from making shows like Death
Note and Black Lagoon to high school
they're dead something so
unapologetically obvious with this
intention and marketing tips tips and
zombies and yet to became one of the
biggest animes in 2010 but of course as
always the FMA Brotherhood approach aka
The Hollywood approach taking a popular
old show which was either unfinished or
differentiated from its original source
material and remaking it with updated
animation and maybe a slightly different
storyline just like other remaking
berserk or Halloween making hunter x
hunter or ramona Kenshin or Evangelion
all you get the point and as much as I
love these shows and the idea of a
remake for them I would like some
original titles too now I know some
snarky comments are watching is just
waiting praying ready to throw me the
sturgeons law arguments what his
sturgeons law in response to critics in
the 1950s often deriding their their new
science fiction genres mostly low
quality and crap
Theodore sturgeon a science fiction
author responded by saying 90% of
everything is crap noting that the
majority of what's in other fields were
of equal low quality with no difference
in regard to other arts this has come to
be known as sturgeons law 90% of films
90% of books and in this case 90% of
anime are generally crap and so for
anyone about to say that the majority of
anime coming out has always been crap
yes I would agree it is true now I was
through five years ago and what's true
in the 90s
what's our Margaery is that the best
original anime in the past four years
doesn't begin to match up to the best of
animes that came out before especially
in my personal last great year of anime
2007 to help you make my point I'll take
my personal favorite animes from 2005 to
2007 and compare it to I've seen some
you know most popular or critically
acclaimed anime coming up from 2008
onwards
3 2008 we have death notes Code Geass
gurren lagaan Barca no black Laguna
Rekha 7 Dakin in black nana and Full
Metal Panic the second raid from 2008
onwards we have Angel Beats even of the
east baton monogatari
do another Madoka Magica and Ohana and
most recently Stein's gates oh and
there's also K on but I'm sure we all
know my opinion of it by now
[ __ ] t's ok so I'm probably
gonna piss a few people off here but I
see think these new animes just aren't
as good yep Angel Beats a very funny
anime with a very interesting concept
that was ultimately let down by lack of
runtime and an incredibly bland main
character not forgetting that love this
was also a slice-of-life comedy anyway
Eden of the East a very interesting
mystery series with an intricate plot
that fell short during its two three at
rakul conclusions back in monogatari a
Nazi anime that on one hand has some of
the most well written and witty dialogue
I've ever seen and on the other hand
have fallen asleep watching on numerous
occasions
Tarara which had the potential to be as
good as Barkin / decided to focus on the
wrong characters Madoka Magica a
breakdown of the merry magical school
genre which admittedly I haven't
actually seen yet Anna Hana a great
tear-jerking high school drama even if
it's not really what I'm looking for in
the first place and steins gate a
gripping time-travel thriller which is
the best thing i've seen recently but
even half that was a slice-of-life
comedy with a time-travel twist not
saying that my past favourites were
perfect either but they packed way more
punch for me keep in mind I had to go
through many blogs and websites to find
stuff that stood out there wasn't purely
slice of life or Maui and the majority
of my favorite new ones are from 2011
anyway so is there anything I'm missing
here some epic gripping anime that
hasn't either been a sequel or remake
and that can make me stop something like
some old-school anime a latest bitching
but more in slice of life but hey you
know what else came out in 2007
something to think about so here we
stand down near the end of 2011 the best
year of anime for Warner but in my
opinion is still not back out there
where it should be or am I wrong have I
just been completely ignorant these past
few years and become one of those
elitist mcenany animes cuz I can't get
past nostalgia of my other favorites I
don't know what do you guys think has
anime been lacking recently be sure to
leave your own opinion in the comment
section or even better why not make a
video response anyway I hope you've
enjoyed a less humorous more serious
video for me and I'll see you all with a
new review next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]